of can you choose to fall in love I
think I kind of think you can to some
extent choose to fall in love I've been
in situations with women decision and I
could have made the opposite decision so
I think it's um and when and when I when
I've done that this is my experience
when I've done that I've then allowed
the chemicals to flood my brain and
those those feelings to come into play
and then you become sort of addicted you
know you can become addicted to a person
in in the same way that you might become
addicted to a drug and it's it's
incredibly real the experience is
incredibly real but it is just a
physiological uh infestation right it's
um you know without wanting to be
unromantic about